[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video i'm going to be discussing
one of the deathly hallows
in fact i'm going to be discussing what
is arguably the most important
of the halos at least in terms of the
harry potter story
i am of course talking about the elder
wand the elder wand is undeniably the
most powerful one
in the harry potter universe it was the
first halo created
made by death himself and no other wand
is its equal
the elder wand is made of elder wood and
its core is the tail hair of ethestral
it's 15 inches long and has carvings
down its length that resemble clusters
of elderberries
with the elder wand witches and wizards
are able to effortlessly produce
intensely powerful magic that others
could only dream of
possession of the wand also meant that
you could produce magic
which was not otherwise possible
including things like mending of the
ones
something that could not normally be
achieved through magic
the elder wand being one of the deathly
hallows is commonly associated with the
tale of three brothers
antioch cadmus and ignotus the brothers
were all members of the famous peverell
family the plot surrounds the three
wizard brothers and their ability to
cheat death
for a short period of time after
conquering death a personification of
death
under the guides of congratulating them
told each of the brothers that he would
award them
with a gift of their choosing the eldest
brother
a combative man asked for a wand more
powerful
than any in existence death grounded his
wish by fashioning the elder wand from a
branch of a nearby elder tree
standing on the banks of the river the
second brother an arrogant man
chose to further humiliate death and
asked for the power to recall the
deceased from the grave
death granted his wish by crafting the
resurrection stone
from a stone picked from the river bank
the third and youngest brother
who is the most humble and wise did not
trust death
and asked for something to enable him to
go forth without death being able to
follow
a reluctant death most unwillingly
handed over a part of his own
invisibility cloak
the three brothers took their prizes and
soon went on their separate ways
and that was how the deathly hallows
were born however this was not the last
time that death and the three brothers
would meet
each brother under their own unique
circumstances ended up losing her life
and met death once more
the eldest brother traveled to a village
where a wizard whom he had quarreled
lived he sought out a jewel and fought
the wizard using the wand
instantly killing the latter leaving his
enemy dead upon the floor
the eldest brother walked to an end not
far from the dueling site
and spent the night there taken by his
conscience and lust of the elder one's
power
the eldest brother boasted of this wand
gifted by death
and his own invincibility that very
night death transfigured to a murderous
wizard
the unknown murderous wizard crept to
the inn as the eldest brother slept
drunk from wine the wizard slit the
oldest brother's throat
for good measure and stole the wand that
was when death took the first brother
so the oldest brother antioch died and
death assuming the form of a murderous
wizard
stole the wand back we know that
dumbledore later becomes owner of the
elder wand
as it plays an integral part in the
harry potter story however
what i want to do in this video is fill
in the gaps and discuss
who owned the elder wand before
dumbledore throughout history
who were the owners of the elder wand
let's get started
so antioch was the first owner but one
thing that i thought was worth
mentioning
is that albus dumbledore never believed
that the wand was actually made
by death dumbledore always assumed that
the wand was in fact created by the
eldest of the peverell brothers
antioch himself however regardless of
who created the fabled wand
the fact remains antioch was killed and
the wand no longer belonged to him
so where did the wand go next according
to xenophilia's love good
the bloody trail of the elder wand is
splattered across the pages of wizarding
history
after antioch died the wand was passed
around from wizard to wizard
usually by violent means which led to
the wand acquiring a few different names
the death stick and the wand of destiny
an omen of death
that alludes to the bloody trail
mentioned by lovegood
the first official known historical
owner of the elder wand
is a wizard who went by the name
emmerich the evil though the wand may
have been in the hands of other wizards
before emmerich
and after antioch america is the first
wizard on record to have possessed it
emmerich has been described as a
short-lived but exceptionally aggressive
wizard that terrorized the south of
england in the early middle ages
it has been expressed that emmerich
eventually died after losing a jewel
to a rival wizard egbert the egregious
egbert the egregious of course became
the new master of the elder wand after
defeating and killing emmerich the evil
its previous owner in the duel
besting the previous owner in some way
is thought to be how the wand is passed
on
and where previously it was thought that
murder was necessary
this was later disproved as in some
cases disarming the current owner is
enough
no one knows what happened to egbert
after defeating emmerich or how long he
possessed the one for
however the next known owner of the wand
came about a century later
the next known owner of the elder wand
was a wizard by the name of godallo
if this name sounds familiar to you it
may be because godallo wrote the famous
dark magic textbook
magic most evil a book containing
information on dark magic
including a passing reference to
horcruxes in its introduction
godelo used the elder wand to push the
boundaries of magic
and considered it to be his teacher
allowing the one to help him write the
book
godello was killed by his own son who
locked him in the cellar in order to
gain ownership of the wand
the next owner was a wizard by the name
of herowood who was of course golow's
son
little is known about heroin but we do
know that he ultimately lost possession
of the wand
as it went on to a new owner the next
known master of the elder wand was a
wizard by the name of barnabas devrel
in the early 18th century utilizing the
wand devil earned quite the reputation
as a fearsome warlock devrel certainly
didn't use the wand for good
and eventually his reign of terror ended
when he was defeated by a rival wizard
the next known owner of the elder wand
the wizard who defeated barnabas was a
man by the name of loxius
loxius is the man who famously gave the
elder wand the name
the death stick and ruthlessly murdered
many people utilizing the wand
loxius was a truly evil dark wizard but
many wanted dead
and according to dumbledore many claimed
to have been the one to finish him off
even his own mother because no one knew
who killed him
this point in history is a bit blurry
with regards to who became the next
owner of the wand
however from xenophilius lovegood's
understanding of history
he believed that it was one of two
wizards arcus or oblivious
two wizards that we don't know very much
about after this point in history
things are a bit blurry and the next
known owner of the wand was one shop
owner
bq kagorovich who you've probably heard
of before
this is the point at which the history
of the wand enters familiar territory
as after miku gained the one's
possession he bragged about it in order
to promote his shop
the wand was then subsequently stolen by
none other than gelat grindelwald
a man you've probably heard of before
grindelwald held the elder wand for many
years
and used it to tyrannize the wizarding
world however when he was eventually
defeated in 1945 by albus dumbledore
dumbledore became the one's new owner
and he held onto it for quite some time
the next owner of the wand was draco
malfoy who during the battle
of the astronomy tower disarmed
dumbledore no one knew that he'd become
the one's rightful owner at that point
particularly as snape was the one to end
dumbledore's life everyone previously
thought the defeat was necessary for the
one to change hands
however nonetheless draco malfoy was the
one's new owner through disarming alone
our very own harry potter becomes the
next and the final owner of the elder
wand
almost a year after draco becomes its
owner when he takes stricker's ones by
force during the skirmish at the malfoy
manor
shortly after harry becomes the one's
new owner however he puts an end to the
bloody trail of the elder wand
i'm putting the other one back where it
came from it can stay there
if i die a natural death like ignotus
its power will be broken
won't it the previous master will never
have been defeated
that'll be the end of it and that's it
for this video
if you enjoyed it please like the video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams and forget
to live
you